revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Marta Moya ya está con
nosotros en el estudio Marta buena
mañana de martes ahí haciendo juego con
tu nombre Marta empezamos en Brasil
donde a cinco días para la primera
vuelta de las elecciones el presidente
volvió a poner en duda si aceptará el
resultado de las urnas porque qué está
pasando en Brasil Hola Raúl buenos días
Así es como lo comentaba también la
compañera lea en su informe abrimos con
carta capital que recoge Este martes
esta entrevista que hizo ayer el
presidente Jair bolsonaro con la
televisión
récord donde volvió a amenazar con no
respetar el resultado de las elecciones
titula carta capital bolsonaro amenaza
una vez más con cuestionar el resultado
electoral dijo el sonaro que pues no
tendría problema en bueno reconocer los
resultados si las elecciones eran
limpias tenemos que saber ahora que son
las elecciones limpias para el
presidente Bueno qué dice Está dado está
dado titula bolsonaro acusa al tribunal
superior electoral de persecución y Evi
quiere decir si aceptará una eventual
derrota También en esta entrevista
volvió a proferir críticas contra este
órgano encargado de velar por el buen
resultado o sea por el buen desarrollo
de las elecciones vamos a Estados Unidos
el New York Times hace un análisis en el
que bueno analiza si este Tribunal
Superior electoral está excediéndose en
sus límites por la defensa de la
Democracia dice que bueno se ha
convertido en el principal contrapeso
del poder a Jair bolsonaro pero que esto
también podría estar suponiendo una
Bueno una un menor una de menor defensa
de la Democracia porque dice que a
partir de 2019 este tribunal con su
líder a la cabeza Alexander morais bueno
de forma unilateral aplico amplió sus
poderes y se otorgó a sí mismo poderes
que le permiten hacer al mismo tiempo de
investigador de juez y de fiscal Así que
critica un poco de tribunal y si se está
excediendo en sus funciones cambiamos
ahora de tema Marta Porque el funeral de
estado del ex Primer Ministro japonés
xinzo ave ha destapado una fuerte
polémica entre la política y la sociedad
por los presuntos vínculos del gobierno
con una iglesia que esta fue a miles de
personas vulnerables y también en la que
ave estaba muy vinculado Así es
empezamos con alguien que titula la
controversia vinculada al asesinato de
ave los problemas políticos de Japón
sostiene que el asesino de hecho ya
magami el asesino confeso del ex Primer
Ministro japonés xinzoave fue víctima de
esta iglesia de la unificación que
habría estafado a miles de personas en
Japón durante décadas Incluso se ha
creado una comisión de víctimas de estas
de esta iglesia por la que se habrían
estafado más de 850 millones de dólares
investigaciones de medios japoneses
además sostienen los vínculos entre esta
iglesia y el partido liberal democrático
que es el partido de xinzoave que ganó
las elecciones y además Bueno pues el
Primer Ministro cachida ha sufrido un
gran revés de popularidad después de
todas estas investigaciones sus
popularidad se situaba en
aproximadamente el 63%, y a raíz de
estos vínculos con esta iglesia que
habría estafado a Bueno a miles de
japoneses su popularidad ha caído al
29%. volvemos al New York Times con este
tema Marta Así es el New York Times
titula porque Japón está enfadado por un
funeral de estado para un líder
asesinado sostiene que bueno Los
japoneses dicen que este funeral es un
derroche de dinero público y más cuando
pues estas investigaciones que comentaba
sostienen estos vínculos entre el
partido liberal democrático y esta
iglesia que habría estafado a muchos
japoneses Además sostienen sostienen
este artículo que el relato del asesino
confeso ha generado incluso empatía
entre los japoneses que también han sido
Víctimas de este fraude cerramos con el
que es uno de los temas más importantes
en Europa Marta tras la historia de
Georgia melón y en Italia la llegada de
la ultraderecha a la tercera economía de
la eurozona y como digamos se recomponen
de alguna manera las fuerzas políticas
tras Este preocupante triunfo para la
Unión Europea si Raúl hoy destacamos la
portada de liberación de Francia que
titula fascismo en Europa todos los
miedos llevan a Roma haciendo un juego
de palabras con esta frase De que todos
los caminos llevan a Roma ahora todos
los miedos llevan a Roma con este
ascenso de la ultraderecha con la
victoria de meloni sostiene en
Liberación la incontestable victoria de
meloni infla el poder de los
ultraconservadores de extrema derecha
que ponen en duda los valores de la
Unión Europea Qué dice el orden mundial
el orden mundial analiza un poco la
derecha euroescéptica y dice que ya no
tiene como objetivo principal salirse de
la Unión Europea sino cambiarla desde
dentro Esta es un análisis del compañero
Emilio Ortiz que dice que ya pues no
está entre estos principales objetivos
frenar o deshacer la integración europea
sino crear una esperanza de Naciones
donde los poderes se transfieran a los
Estados y no recaigan en la comisión
europea además dice que Polonia y
Hungría estos miembros disco los de la
unión Pues con el brexit Bueno
desafiaron un poco deshicieron pero este
objetivo de salirse de la unión Y que
ahora lo básico para estos partidos Euro
escépticos es cambiarla desde dentro el
global Times de China Marta para
concluir muy rápidamente el editorial
del global Times este periódico alineado
con el partido comunista chino titula en
su editorial Europa debería Ser valiente
para enfrentar los problemas tras el
giro a la derecha dice que los problemas
se afrontan con actitud pragmática y
racional y constructiva pero que no hay
que dejar de lado atacar si esto se ven
amenazadas así es Marta gracias entonces
por toda la información de la revista de
prensa por el día hoy mañana Por
supuesto con más anti Raúl Gracias hasta